first suppose we are now okay that's
perfect no hi my name is Gracie some
people do don't know now you know your
life is different now I'm here with
Hannah and mamrie Hart
hello insert of wha we were shooting a
bunch of videos for each other's
channels today and in the spirit of the
holiday that is coming up this weekend
Easter I'll for 2000 well do the same
yeah everyone's too saying mine a
surprise Jesus knotweed Oh
oh Jesus a mentor likes Angelus all the
time the thing that we found to have
coming around on in our friendship is
that all of us sort of independent they
really love Jesus Christ Superstar ah
Jesus we haven't seen each other for
weeks I've been converted this is my
video to bring you guys both back into
the home I'll come to Jesus in the sense
that okay we love this movie we've seen
a live production of this movie we each
have our favorites so on I'll see my
eyes I can hardly see huh I mean that
works for both you guys you both wear
glass we are my mom took me to the 25th
anniversary production of Jesus Christ
we start with the original Judas Wow
your mom loves you
superstar in Amsterdam whoa wait these
two I was like oh no it's Iceland also
in doing some actual like Google Image
searching of other like regional
productions of Jesus Christ Superstar
it's up for interpretation so I thought
that we would incorporate that into a
game today that I don't have a good
title for the only title I have right
now is is the Jesus or is it just us Oh
looking at Mary's
super zoomed in photos and you have to
decide if it is a local theaters
production of Jesus Christ Superstar or
picture of the two of you together oh my
god you guys don't have to decide
together
okay so let's begin okay there's our
first zoomed in Wow is that Jesus or is
it just us Wow
I mean it's neither of our hair then
it's great throwing us off someone
wearing a weight room is that like your
aunt wig no we're never not
I think it's Jesus I think it's used
Christ Superstar you think it's a
regional production of jasmine Superstar
I'll answer both khal drogo and like a
vampire sex slave yeah you guys are yeah
I think that's your knee on the leg and
you know legging when did we wear all
black I don't think it I can't tell if
it's probably I think what color's your
suit at the streamys this year oh and
olive green yeah I mean yeah I may be a
thousands of parking yeah I bet it does
I think it's not a see you think it's
you guys yeah yeah final answer
yeah it is you did a really good job
making like I like trying to find
pictures that would be confusing my
camera roll looks really bad really
great like I'll be better than any
disciples all right here's the next one
Wow I've never worn a material that
looks like that but I think Mary
Magdalene would that [ __ ] but it could
be Mardi Gras beads
Marnie when have we gone to Mardi Gras
together huh ma'am of course you don't
remember you were a lot wow wow that I
wasn't there maybe
I know this picture holy Sh no this
picture this is me and you doing that
Lilly Singh video where we both have
almost like crazy yeah no I think it's
our Bollywood video oh my god
oh my god I guess I agree again your
friend Lindsay yes and the answer is yes
never worn a falcon I've never worn a
material that looks like that well
technically I'm not handed good Jeff you
guys are doing really well there's no
winners or losers in this game there are
32 okay here we go here's your next one
that's someone's been the bat a
different girl you are my new scent we
up at the market Jesus your rent is due
hell no okay here's our next one oh okay
this is like your prison suit
oh and we hope you've done superstar us
superheroes no I think that's us I don't
I don't think it finally it says we both
have really I'm not I mean I don't wear
whatever these are screen grabs and
stuff too so they might be a filtered
for deception I mean it's just what
comes up on when you google image search
the - it looks very fabric II okay well
I don't let me just say it's Jesus
Christ Superstar gonna say it
okay let's face it we serve yeah and
you're right
oh that's that one number where he's
like all crazy yeah are you sure they
said he took shrooms before you went
sell this so you would be safe I used to
this is it the Technicolor Dreamcoat
show I'm sorry what what the hell is
that okay is that a flower right so why
can I touch it you can touch it just be
careful I think it's like Voldemort is
that wine saying didn't you have like
wine stains and the design of your first
cookbook I liked it I would say us but I
can't say from where same okay it's you
guys uh-huh and you are correct orange
hair like this is a new form of theater
mass shooting that so hard
Hannah was so high you know what I would
have done it no matter what she stuck
her bra the next one no like Taylor
Christ I didn't say anything we're at a
crossroads oh here we go
wait is that my hair is that the
previous photo no ooh
was I ever in some sort of crustacean
costume definitely I'm not thinking
about anything right now
Wow I think it's she's crazy to say I
need you and the answer is yes just
looks like an accountant at this guy was
everyone's biggest crush in school yeah
these were the best years of your life
that's what that's for sure a fake beard
right yeah wow that's a big
okay that looks like that looks like
your head that looks like us but me fame
it made me remember what gotta remember
dealin grace helbig juice she probably
found somebody with lily white hair and
zoomed in I think it's what's that
purpley backdrop I never seen that
before my life
maybe it's the backdrop of one of our no
filter shows so we didn't pay attention
to it the backdrop was I think that's
you
I've done or it's Andy Warhol starring
as Jesus Christ I think it's not me man
I don't want my hair so wait it's a wavy
is it me
[Music]
I don't think it's me I don't know all
right and here's where we where we
fundraise today your income back on my
do you think it's you in an antenna you
think it's Jesus Christ Superstar aya
theater production
correct and the correct answer is it
looks like a no filter shows a good kind
of haystack furry spider could we
I think it's Jesus Christ Superstar or
baked something we're cooking do you
have a shirt that color teal yeah from
years ago maybe when I cut your bangs no
no I was providing different
I think it's JC s yes I'm now VCS ok
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a wrapping paper and that's a
decorative item that we had hey man look
at go zoom in on me right there ok this
is last oh that's the first time we do
know why dad because that is the
Hibiscus infused tequila you are
absolutely correct
good job you guys think yeah basically
yeah really great job how did you guys
do playing along at home
well that's X you're not yet I can make
sure you guys go check out how to make
me channels to make videos over there we
did a milk test over on Hannah so we did
a mystery taste but we did mystery taste
buds they come cheated nope yep then on
memories Channel mysteriously our
cousin's showed up and things got pretty
sexy so go check that out over
other than that like subscribe leave
comments all those fun things I make
videos no oven then I don't know
remember the one number do treasure
superstar where he's like yeah Hardy oh
man we got to have another production
guys but Rainbow Brite I know there's no
Fraggles like oh yeah it's great
okay here's the next one I'm gonna say
that's us just cuz why would you throw
it hurry yeah okay it's us you think
it's you guys that's us
wait wait no because one more time let
me just do it like doing math twice in a
row I'm doing that cuz she we would know
that we were tricked the last time no
matter what so if we hadn't gotten it we
would be like you're tricking us so it
means it is us
so your answer hasn't changed from you
making me wait I mean now I think